the next two talks in addition to being
a universal or Lou and hoping to run
this thing this works up I'm also a
judge on the AI X PRIZE which has been
happening on for last couple years
they've whittled it down from 150 teams
from around the world that are working
on AI for good problems and in response
for a on the goal of getting a few
million dollar surprise and they
whittled down now to 20 teams over every
year that's kind of like checkpoints and
awards and this this week in in Montreal
we had a milestone checkpoint of the top
ten teams of the remaining 20 and we
selected two of those teams to come here
and give a short accepted talks and the
first one today is gonna be from Zach
hello everyone my name is Rob Ella and
I'll be talking about how sap is using
artificial intelligence to fight malaria
and towards malaria elimination so
malaria used to be everywhere all over
the globe today it's been eliminated in
many countries and 90% of the malaria
burden is now in sub-saharan Africa
still over a third of the world's
population is at risk of contracting
malaria and every year there's 300
million cases new cases reported leading
to over 450,000 deaths and in addition
to being a fatal people who get sick
with malaria can't go to work and go to
school and also leads to a loss in
development in addition to the actual
cost of malaria interventions the whu-oh
set a goal for 2030 for to eradicate
malaria in over 35 countries but
recently this year after a decade where
each year the reduction in malaria has
been smaller and smaller this year we're
not seeing any reduction in the
prevalence of malaria the methods are
becoming less and less effective
so what methods are there there's most
of the methods to target the actual
mosquitoes that transmit the disease the
Anopheles mosquitoes methods such as
spreading the inside walls of a house so
that when a mosquito lands on it before
after they bite she bites she dies in
cannot transmit the disease
there's bed nets way that you sleep
under they're treated with insecticides
spraying of water bodies that is
effective against the mosquito larvae
how they need water to develop and those
three target the actual mosquitoes
there's one method that targets the
actual Plasmodium parasite which is
distribution of anti malarial drugs on a
large scale to an entire community at
once the problem is that the
effectiveness of each of these methods
in a given location depends on many
factors for example the method of
spraying water bodies in areas that are
very scarcely populated or areas that
are very where there's a lot of
precipitation or swampy areas there's
too many water sources or water bodies
per person for this method to be
cost-effective another example is the
ratio between indoor biting mosquitos
and outdoor biting mosquitos methods
like bed nets and house praying are not
effective if outdoor biting mosquitoes
are more prevalent and actually there's
many interactions and many factors that
are that make it difficult to select an
optimal intervention for for a given
location so far the solution has been
blanket interventions which means taking
one of the methods or two of the methods
that are most commonly used and
implementing them over large areas which
leads to an inefficient use of resources
and basically using interventions that
are ineffective in certain areas anyway
because of the the lack of planning
that's offered so our solution is an AI
enhanced planning tool that all
basically
zooom the role of the malaria expert in
deciding what interventions should be
performed where and it does it by
looking at individual communities
offering individual communities
different interventions so this is an
example of what recommendation might
look like for example a big city where
there's fewer water sources per person
larvae sighting may be more effective
which is treating the the water bodies
but in smaller areas or in areas that
are far from from water there may be
different interventions that would be
recommended so I want to show an example
of how we're using artificial
intelligence to to develop this planning
tool so I'll give the example of the
spatial factor how how we know we could
of course that this is a demonstration
of a village a simplified map of a
village we're in brown you see the
houses and in blue you see the water
bodies and of course the best method
would be to spray all of the houses and
spray all of the breeding sites the
larval habitats and that would of course
get the most reduction in malaria but
the problem is that there's limited
budgets and you have to decide you have
to decide how you're going to maximize
your budget and if you have an area so
what we can do is we can take advantage
of the a synergistic effect between
different methods and spray some of the
houses spray some of the breeding sites
and get a better result - so this is an
example of what it would look like we're
in green are treated houses and in
orange are treated breeding larval
habitats
so these representative maps of villages
we take and we use to Train
convolutional neural network that
basically enables us to predict how what
the mosquito population would behave
given a certain intervention by knowing
the mosquito population we also know if
the intervention is going to be
sufficient for malaria elimination and
also the duration that it would take to
reach malaria elimination in that
location given the fact that there are
many possible combinations we
Spray any number of houses any number of
water bodies we use simulated annealing
to find the optimal solution the optimal
combination when we evaluated the
algorithm and the recommendations we
used simulated data to show that the
recommendations made by the algorithm
perform better than both random
strategies which is just spray randomly
given your budget and also compared to
strategies informed by research such as
spraying houses that are around water
bodies because that's where the more
mosquitoes would be or spraying around
the border of the village which is
actually something that came up when we
were looking at the results that were
being recommended by the algorithm right
so this is using simulated data but we
also would like to get real data and
actually our first product was a mobile
app it's a GPS based mobile app and it's
used to facilitate the implementation of
interventions in the field so a big
problem was the thoroughness of the
interventions employees would be would
would be given a village to scan for
water sources and 40% of the water sort
water bodies would be missed or they
would be they would need to spray houses
and they wouldn't know which houses have
already been sprayed which hasn't need
to be sprayed so this app helps them it
guides them around the village lets them
know what houses need to be treated but
what areas they've already scanned it as
you can see in the picture on the right
it kind of marks where they've been and
shows them where they need to go to to
continue scanning and we tested this app
in Ghana this year this May and it
showed we were able to show that workers
guided by the app found 28% more of the
larval habitats compared to the methods
that they were being that were being
used before so data that we collect
using this app will also
allow us to train our model further
further our neural network further we've
already implemented the app in in Ghana
and in Kenya and we're implementing it
next year in Zanzibar also trying to
collaborate with the South Africa and
Ministry of Health and the Senegalese
Ministry of Health and that's us in
Ghana and we're trying to get various
sites so that we have different kinds of
data because different places are using
different interventions and we're not
really telling that telling them what to
use yet we're kind of gathering
information first about what's happening
what's being used in it how effective it
is by monitoring the mosquito population
using traps first so that we can train
our model and then move on to actually
testing if the model works in real life
by giving recommendations that perform
better another project where we're doing
next next year in Zanzibar is
incorporating drones to scan because
they can scan faster than the people as
well as satellite imagery to identify
the areas that we should be focusing on
so we're kind of incorporating our
technology there and this specific
project was supported by the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation which is deals
mostly with malaria so yeah this is us
in the field locating larval habitats
which hopefully we'll use to train our
algorithm and be able to inform malaria
elimination campaigns
I think there's time for questions right
yes so if there are any questions
you finished earlier happen great
has anyone have a question I will say
first that I am NOT one of the
programmers on this I'm more on the
implementation side so I'm not sure I'm
gonna be able to answer all the
technical questions but I'll try to the
best of my knowledge do you have 1
million either
thanks how would you compare the models
that you're developing with some of the
other model modeling work going on in
mechanistic simulation models for
example so he could you repeat that how
would you compare your machine learning
models with some of the other work going
on in more statistical mechanistic
simulation models for malaria
interventions ok so basically a lot of
the things we're doing have to do with
spatial information so it's very useful
for us to know to be able to tell from
satellite imagery things about the the
intervention area so we're trying to
incorporate some machine vision into our
so far where you've been using the app
so the app kind of helps you map out the
village in addition to satellite imagery
with manual tagging so we're looking
into incorporating a machine vision into
that and so we're using convolutional
neural networks for this specific
purpose but data that is more to do with
climate and precipitation things like
that could be we might be looking at
differently so yeah if that answers your
question no one has a so very
interesting work I wanted to ask if it
would make sense to have in your could
based baseline whereby you just gave the
smartphone's with some you know very
simple baseline to see whether the
impact was based on the smartphone or
your machine learning based guidance
right so so the first step would be the
baseline the first we're not going to be
when you're using the data to train the
the algorithm but we're you know the
first step is the bit is gonna be the
baseline information and you know
companies will be using the mobile app
for the benefit of increasing the
coverage of the interventions it's
separate from the planning stage so the
planning stages is an additional product
that we're kind of making use of the
data that we collect using the the
mobile app that on its own has a lot of
value to the to these campaigns to also
provide additional value great okay
thank the speaker again thank you very
much for listening
[Applause]